good morning John you said you'd see me
on Wednesday and so you are the bad news
is that because this is just some random
day I don't actually have anything make
a video about the good news is that's
how it always used to be it's kind of
fun I do actually have one thing that I
wanted to share with everyone and that
is that I have a rash covering my entire
body according to my doctor it's a side
effect of some kind of viral infection
that I probably got at the Barack Obama
rally Rock give me a ZZ shook my hand
Steve and now I got a fever of 103
barack obama at first i had 103 degree
fever for like five days and then i
start to feel better except that my skin
got all blotchy and then it started to
get itchy at first scratching it is like
complete and total heaven just being
like and then immediately after i stop
scratching it's like itchy scratchy pain
of death and obits oh oh and yes it
covers my entire body except for six
very important parts but there is good
news Hank how could something so
horrible lead to good news I'm glad you
asked that other me because
convalescence can be a wonderful
wonderful time if you spend it correctly
that's been my convalescence listening
to music mostly on YouTube now nobody
should be surprised by this but music is
a very important part of who we are as
people and individuals and as a species
so it's really nice not again to have
time to catch up on your music it's
really too bad that because of copyright
stuff I can't like put it straight into
the video but I will point out and have
links in the sidebar to all of these
people that I wanted to share there it's
something yeah there's something stuck
in my teeth but I'm not gonna go back
and rerecord all that sorry so without
further ado and not like to think of ID
this is Hank Green's top 9 list of
awesome songs he found on YouTube while
sweating and itching in his bed Ultra
relax is in my opinion the pinnacle of
j-pop it was the intro to a show called
Kudo Minoan motor which was about kids
in school yes I have the manga
very own house the song was sung by
Shinohara Tomoya who is an amazing
energetic singer and it's one of my
all-time favorite songs there's also
lots of Japanese people doing stupid
dances so it's pretty much a pinnacle in
terms of Awesomeness there is of course
a B from songs from a hat who I love
I've linked to my scientist in the
sidebar figure mustache speaking of a B
she suggested to me a songwriter called
Julian Nunez who is amazing first she's
a nerdfighter which is awesome the
second she writes amazing songs and has
an amazing voice and deserves every
single ounce of the fame that she's
going to have in two years time
speakin of all of those people they're
definitely a YouTube community that's
sort of surrounding really good singer
songwriters and see so Narciso Lobo I
think it looked really active in that
community and he is an amazing
songwriter he does a lot of covers but
his originals are by far better than the
covers and I've linked to the song we
never wrote over there this was a
completely random find um a woman called
Gustav who I think it's German
doesn't sound like English is
necessarily her first language but the
song is in English it's called we shall
overcome probably the best song that I
stumble across this year so I'm sort of
like yes everybody go check that out
recently I've been loving onsen
wizard-rock parcel mouths and the
moaning myrtles both have members
prominently featured in five awesome
girls I've been listening to a lot of of
Montreal and finally I wanted to share
this amazing version of cotton fields
originally like a really sort of the
laid-back country song but somebody did
arrangement for Teresa Brewer who was a
famous singer in the 1940s and 50s that
just has yodeling and really weird
choreography and just like from the
belly rocking out singing stuff and it's
just amazing to watch so I want to share
that with everyone as well so those are
my finds of the week but I'm really
curious what other people been listening
to lately
what are nerd fighters listen to my
voice is completely going because verily
that's where the disease is moving now
because I've been to my skin and now
it's going to my throat I don't see in
comments any you know mainstream obscure
whatever you got I'm looking for good
music I kind of trust you guys to have
good taste and John I'll see you next
week I guess Oh before then you said you
were gonna do a question Tuesday but not
on Tuesday so I'll see you before the
week is out or else you'll be punished
my watch is done I gotta go